prendre la direction de l'ukraine pour
retrouver notre correspondant sur place
gilbert crack bonjour vous êtes à comme
hunting si vous êtes à 250 kilomètres de
kiev où en sont les combats gulliver là
où vous vous trouvez
là où je me trouve bien évidemment il
n'y a pas de combats dans le sens où il
n'y a pas de troupes russes au sol mais
ce périodiquement il y à des tirs de
roquettes j'en ai pas entendu
aujourd'hui mais ces jeunes terre n'est
joué il ya eu des tirs de roquettes
visant une base aérienne je pense ou une
base militaire juste à côté à une
vingtaine de kilomètres d'ici il y a eu
des tirs sur plusieurs endroits dans
l'ouest de l'ukraine des cibles
militaires pour la plupart et surtout il
y à cette impression que tout le pays
est sur le pied de guerre les hommes qui
se mobilisent pour rejoindre les forces
armées ou bien qu'ils mettent des
checkpoints en place il y a les femmes
qui fabriquent des blindages pour
l'armée une mobilisation vraiment très
grande même ici au village par exemple
des villageois à nous ils nous
emmenaient des produits alimentaires 10
ans et pour les déplacés dont dans un
certain sens j'en fais partie même si on
les a assurés que on avait on avait de
l'argent que des magasins sont en cours
ouverts et qu'on n'avait pas vraiment
besoin de ça mais on a l'impression que
tout le monde essaye de faire ce qu'il
peut pour aider et il est assez très
très grande inquiétude aujourd'hui au vu
de cette colonne de tanks qui s'achemine
vers kiev et de ses bombardements sur
archives puis je ne pense qu on ne le
soulignera jamais suffisamment de fois
est une ville russophone un gulliver
comment justement
comment la population voit la posture de
volodymyr zelensky qui quittent jamais
un chef de guerre qui s'exprime devant
les européens en dix ans ont montré que
vous êtes avec nous
oui d'abord il faut dire que volodymyr
zelensky était loin de faire l'unanimité
chez les ukrainiens avant le début de
cette guerre beaucoup d'ukrainiens
surtout les ukrainiens avec un niveau
plus élevé d'éducation les classes
moyennes étaient très critiques envers
le président beaucoup se moquer de lui
tout ça est vraiment fini on voit les
gens qu il absolument qui salue son
courage le fait qu'il est sorti faire
cette vidéo dans la rue à quai pour
montrer qu'il était encore là qu'il a
absolument refuser de quitter la ville
avait vu beaucoup d'ukrainiens regarder
les messages vidéo régulière que
volodymyr zelensky fait pour le peuple
ukrainien parfois aussi en s'adressant
au peuple russes en russe en les
appelant à se rebeller contre le pouvoir
russe je vois les ukrainiens regarder
ses messages les armes les larmes aux
yeux bien sûr cette demande d'une
adhésion urgente à l'union européenne
est quelque chose qui semblait
absolument impossible et peut-être que
c'est encore impossible mais je pense
que beaucoup d'ukrainiens pense que
c'est la bonne chose à faire et on a vu
ces derniers jours des chutes des choses
qui semblait absolument impossible qui
se sont produites comme par exemple le
fait que l'allemagne on voit des armes à
l'ukraine et puis ces sanctions contre
la russie qui sont vraiment
de sorte à pouvoir porter un coup très
dur à la l'économie russe ce qui déjà en
cours d'ailleurs avec la chute du rouble
mais bien sûr les ukrainiens surtout ils
disent que tout cela vient un peu trop
tard et que c'est depuis 2014 qu'il
aurait fallu commencer à penser à ne
plus acheter le gaz russe à prendre une
action beaucoup beaucoup plus
conséquente contre la russie de vladimir
poutine 2014 quand la russie à alex et
la crimée et a commencé la guerre dans
l'est de l'ukraine merci beaucoup
gulliver que l'hiver